- GET THE HELL OUT OF HERE, YOU PIG-TOSSERS!
♪♪♪
- What is UP, my baby football dudes?!
Us sophomores are here for your orientation.
- Nice try, freshman. I like a mature QB.
- Aight, here's the deal, bros.
Over there you got the divas.
Clipboard-holders.
Defensive stars who NEED to make up for their team’s offense.
White receivers.
- Did you know volcanoes can’t harm healthy men?
- [Justin Herbert:] Josh Allens.
Linemen we don’t have the budget to animate.
Texans. Do NOT sit there.
Sexually active kickers.
And King B and the GOATs. These dudes are, like, hot as s--t, bro.
- I saw you in college. You’re really good at football.
- So you agree? You think you’re really good at football?
- AT PRACTICE, WE WEAR RED!
- Tom Brady is, like, perfection.
- He’s so cool, we’re breaking the fourth wall to tell you.
- One time he scored 31 unanswered points in the Super Bowl.
… It was awesome.
- I don’t think my fiancee, Shailene Woodley from "Divergent,"
would like this.
- Oh, yeah, this whole thing is about how being popular makes you insecure.
[School bell ringing]
- [Tom Brady:] I found this bulletin-board material. I think the rookies made it.
- "The Browns are Serious Contenders." This can never get out.
- Mm, too late.
- Oh, @$%#, expectations.
- "Henry is due for a decrease in production"? Oh, they lyin', lyin'.
- Why is mine a whole chapter? I’ve only played ONE season, everyone.
- Do they know everything, or just the crab leg stuff?
- ENOUGH!
OK, who here has been personally owned by Tom Brady?
- ME, RECENTLY!
- ♪♪♪ Yo, I think we should all just alooong. ♪♪♪
- He doesn't even go here!
- [Roger Goodell:] STOP HIDING IN OUR STADIUMS, KANYE!
- Look, everyone. I’m sorry if my greatness infuriates you,
but I dare you to come at me!
- Taunting!
- [Together:] Aw, come on!
- Boooo!
- Why should only Caesar be allowed to join a new team
and  recruit all his old friends to play with him?
Brutus is just as cute as Caesar, right? Brutus is a better pure passer than Caesar.
People totally think Brutus would make a better Jeopardy host than Caesar,
and when did it become okay for one QB to win every ring,
That’s not what ROME is all about!
We should totally just STAB CAESAR!
Yeah so I’m just happy to be back and playing for the Packers.